[Applause]
the
verbal abuse was the worst i've ever
heard
killed the police uh shame on you
and arrest your own and then to me
personally that i should be raped and
murdered
somebody said that to your face more
than one person said that to me yes
sergeant imogen hurst was right in the
thick of the crowd
at the sarah everard vigil she says
there were groups there
less concerned about peaceful observance
set instead
on confrontation it was just
very very violent there were a lot of
pushing and shoving i was personally
assaulted i was hit three times in the
chest
but a fortnight on from the events which
caused such widespread alarm
many who were there in the crowd
believed the police could have adopted a
more hands-off approach
they're not being held accountable for
what went down they're not being held
accountable for creating the situation
that they found themselves in
placing blame on us and others and the
women that
arrived on the night seems
seems quite evident to me to be evidence
of the systemic
misogyny within the met police her
majesty's inspector of constabulary
who looked in great detail at the way in
which the vigil was policed
said it had been extremely complex and
challenging
the police they conclude acted
appropriately and were not heavy-handed
for senior commanders here at scotland
yard this report
is an almost complete vindication of the
policing operation on the 13th of march
in fact some of the few criticisms in
the report
are mainly focused on the senior
politicians who were quick to condemn
the police tactics
people not just politicians but there
were others
need to be quite careful about jumping
to conclusions before they've got to the
bottom of facts
particularly of course because in doing
so there's always a danger that you can
undermine
public confidence in policing and just
make things more difficult in the future
the london mayor effectively the met
commissioner's boss
was one of the first to criticize the
policing of the vigil
at the time describing it as neither
appropriate
or proportionate however the home
secretary who described the scenes at
the time as upsetting
has now thrown her complete support
behind the police
quite frankly i was absolutely appalled
and sickened
to see the level of violence that was
being displayed to
police officers but whatever the
official report concludes
there's the public perception of
high-profile events like the clapham
vigil
and that can prove far more difficult to
change
mark white sky news